i don't this is not a lydia this isn't a
[ __ ] rum but
but we see it's not a dragon
thing
yeah wow nobody with that thing that
we've been talking about that has been
popping up as of late in dojo events and
again with the shaheen
i think this maybe because it's a longer
set they want to get a feel but let's
see how it'll pay off see those roll
dashes coming in from nobody once
i was gonna say the thing is like when
you use your main character and you know
it's arguable that dan's main character
is shaheen the one that he's been using
throughout tekken 7 there's a different
level of understanding when you're able
to play sometimes you could play
instinctively without thinking and
things happen just naturally faster
speaking of instincts that was a great
instinct to hop kick at that point
nobody now in huge trouble oh the
backswing blow lands for nobi oh nice
punish there from uh from again
nice
kind of as we go into this good blocks
there
great tempo step goes for the follow-up
guaranteed damage
and look at this turning the tables here
nobody with a huge life lead here
yeah all for a lot of those pokes come
from that kenpo like again has to be
very uh yeah just careful
nobody gets that second round in
dominant fashion look at that look at
the life lead he had towards the end
there
oh yeah he definitely made that one
count
and again it's all about the approach
and one of the tools i think the
strongest tools that we have from fenway
now is his ability to do way more damage
he got so many buffs just for his
overall damage not only on the ground
but also in combos as well because of
the usage of his moves and look at that
things are just adding up all these
grounded hits loki iron
so much damage coming from nobi he means
business and again oh blocks the
windmills
and let's see if gen can get back in
this match nice interrupt on the down
three and we have yet to see some down
back threes coming out from nobody nice
pick up there
and that's the thing too is like does he
even need to use it at this point he's
been making all the damage and all the
offensive options happen on his own
it's all been about interrupting his
opponent and kind of threading the
needle with his pokes
wow
just
yeah that's been the highlight look at
that no b
still racking up the damage not even
from a launch nice block on this slide
but couldn't capitalize that much now
again
there's an opportunity for him gets the
slide followed up with the ff3
oh he got hit by him
he did
yeah on that rage drive oh my god
usually you guessed it
all right final round here match number
one again this is a race to three
hey fish hook just give him a bait no
down back threes no counter hit luckily
because when he has a back turn there's
a whole lot more mix-ups he has to deal
with oh my god hits him with a hop kick
and look at the way he's just kind of
threatening just by moving into his
space
oh nice block
oh good conversion
oh there we go down back three oh my god
he challenged and again reaping the
rewards there gets the first match but
markman that it was back and forth i'm
excited we got we got a fang in a
shaheen
yeah he got very greedy at the very end
there because you know he got to counter
it down back three puts him into a
background state went for the chunky
back turn three and unfortunately he got
low kicked out of it and he got into the
combo that ended up losing the match so
uh something to think about as you go
into that situation you don't want to be
put into the same situation lose out
time after time again but i'd have to
say from both of these players they both
really showed uh their resolve in going
into the matchup uh very strong showing
from you with fang i feel like you
should probably stick to the character
he definitely did very very well however
for uh again going back to his main main
his old main character shaheen proving
that he's still just as strong with that
character as ever
yeah this is uh like his when when he
first burst it back into the scene from
that hiatus it brought the leo but he
really found a lot of success with with
shaheen and now bringing it out now
i think yeah he's he's conserving his
strength for probably the the later
rounds and this is technically his main
right so bring out the big guns right
away but note that he can go back to
that focus he can go back to the lydia
he's just that good with those
characters as well but with on nobi's
side though i still think yeah maybe
still stick with the fang because it did
yield him some results and uh yeah just
the constant harassment from the pokes
have been paying off and we are going to
kinder gym
kinder jim it is
it's funny too because i'm looking at
the chat and a lot of people are ha they
have comments about character choice you
know you got to remember these guys
aren't picking characters for you
they're picking characters to win
something that you guys can't do so keep
that in mind
okay here we go very true follow up nice
counter hit
okay
nice punish there from
again back turn oh the kenpo once again
but you couldn't get much out of it
though
oh he went for the wall 72 he went for
the big punish
now moving along nicely threatening the
slide but still
hey
oh man
they're both in rage
someone's gonna let it rip oh that's
that's one way to do it
yeah fall damage there down back three
excellent stuff on nobody's side
so we've seen this before right you know
nobody getting some wins but then you
know again is always a constant threat
wow
finds the wall
it's the iron fortress no i'm just
constantly keeping him there but oh gets
the counter hit now again
able to get his back away from the wall
but we see that he does have some rage
nice
reverse kenpo he's gonna have to again
be very wary of that because the reverse
kenpo can get him a lot of advantage if
he goes in wrong with the wrong move man
great block and a great punish there
nobody looking to tie things up
yeah he was waiting for that slide nice
block on the hop kick
oh well time kempo
oh
that was so sick
and he gets good damage off of it here
let's see what he does
while standing too no punish
yep
wow look at them they're standing yeah
they're just baiting some activities
that happen and they want to get big
counter hits big result big swings
and and uh so far nobody though
almost that rage oh gets the shoulder
one more would do it for nobi
yo is he gonna three over
not like this oh he's looked at it too
long
dear headlights
yep
sometimes you just freeze like that and
again
able to act first oh down back three
counter hit
didn't get anything out of it though but
playing it a little more safe than the
previous one
oh yeah and now big combo opportunity
here he's gonna get the wall as well
let's see what ken's able to do okay
wise tries to keep him there goes for
the homing attack
oh slide again
getting so much mileage out of that
slide again
nice interrupts ken just yeah
interrupting him before again could uh
before nobody can get a big swing going
one more would do it
uh just the mid to check him out
this is gonna be a huge round posh
because it comes down to this tied up on
rounds it's either gonna be two zero
games wise for again or it's gonna be
all tied up we'll see what happens oh
wow
okay
nice rising uh just wake up option there
by uh
you know again doing such a great job
with the side step left he's gonna get
blocked
no he got the hair oh my god he caught
him swinging and just as you mentioned
this is gonna be quite the situation for
nobody now because it's too old but all
these rounds have been going a final
round it's been quite close but again
has been able to put the pieces together
the power of youth that clutch rage art
he's up to zero now and nobi is probably
talking to the floor he's his head is
down he is this is not a good situation
to be in not a good situation
the young man reactions right i actually
thought he blocked as well i thought
that nobody was going to get a punish
from that but what a call out from from
genn this is why we talked about it this
is why it's his main the instinct is
there even it put in tough spots right
we saw that gen uh usually gets two
rounds away from it like it's it's
nobody that gets the two rounds first
but again able to claw his way back in
those match in emphatic fashion like
that's three straight rounds technically
he just made the make the adjustment and
his shaheen is looking like it's in top
form
top form indeed but you know i gotta say
you know
nobody's fang is no slouch either he
really put together a brilliant set of
offense especially going into it he had
a nice lead going into match number two
but it wasn't enough he's gonna stick to
feng and and i don't know if that's the
courage and confidence that he had from
the the data that he collected in the
first two matches but he is stuck with
fenway for the entirety of this set he
has to win three straight matches if he
wants to get into the winner's side of
grand finals anyways going into the
match to see how it plays out
yeah it has gone to the final round so
he's it's it's no question that he
committed to this thing that's the iron
palm and to the iron fortress
let's see though again oh my gosh these
slides have been paying so much
dividends for uh again
uh-huh
nice blocks man get it is is so on point
when it comes to situational preparation
oh yeah goes low that time but yeah
again
i mean his offense is really on point
but something to command for him to get
there is his defense have been has been
so good stuff in all the options of uh
nobe but now it's ff3 magic carpet ride
pushing to the wall
oh oh nice oh
you saw that nobody was trying to go for
the kills like just trying to go all out
but yep just tagged him with a down
three
again
still back in this match
oh kata moving twice again the punish
there on the slide he's gonna do decent
damage and also get the wall but the
side walls that still gets the full
combo
okay okay
showing or showing much like we've seen
in previous matches that he can take it
to a round point but will he be able to
clutch it out that's the question
yeah we've seen this story before can he
close this one out again getting that
launch though
nice adjustment yeah a little off axis
but the low parry could change things
for nobi
there you go look at the wall carry has
a good position here let's see what he
does with it however again can get out
of this pretty easily all he has to do
is slice him quite a bit
but he's not gonna let him go he's not
gonna let him out
[Music]
there we go
nobody staying alive yeah he needed
he needed to capitalize on that
situation didn't want him to go anywhere
and for him to just carry him towards
that wall you just this is where the
thing is really paying off because this
could have been the same results of the
previous two matches so you know as you
mentioned he cannot drop a single game
here on out if he wants to head to the
grand finals in winner's side
oh yeah
definitely a very interesting takes you
know we've seen nobi and his approach
and it's how he kind of keeps the
pressure while he's at the wall and he's
always guessed right you know his use of
the lows to kind of really open up and
make again maybe second guess his his
offensive or his defensive capability
there uh i gotta i gotta say you gotta
give it up for no because nobody is so
good at forcing his opponent to kind of
guess at the wall
yeah and just to show also like the
confidence in his offense right you know
when he's already in the
the life deficit he'll just go all out
because he knows that all right i gotta
try my best i gotta just leave it all in
the line and you don't you see no fear
when he's able to do that and
i think knee said it best like nobi like
you know japan has their own style of
tekken but nobody can kind of is like an
exception with that because he's so good
at offense as well and i think that's
the one of the problems he presents
towards again
definitely
i will agree with you there and we get
into another matchup here
nobody living to fight another day
so it's now two to one in favor of again
you know again still needs one more
match to move on to our grand finals
winner side however nobee with that
momentum and with that newfound
offensive confidence will it be enough
to kind of turn the tide here right
you want to see starts it off yeah he
gets blocked
still just these pokes oh wow and now in
that scramble again able to get a launch
yeah and that's quite different from
what we've seen so far from yen is he
has not yet used that tool that down
forward too to kind of interrupt the
flow of his opponent and this time it
ended up working in a brilliant way that
sidestep down 4-2 is something that you
really have to watch out for
mm-hmm
and that's got it nobody's got to take
notice of that don't do it yup he is
and that's gotten nobi's attention
only be able to land it once again just
chopping away the mids goes low to close
that one out
up forward one into the one plus two he
tried to bait him for the punch
he was trying yeah nobody trying to pull
out everything in the book here
second hit nice i like what i'm seeing
here
good block
oh the walk able to punish
but the wake up from again though
still at the center of the stage still
no real estate advantage for any of
these players just yet but wow
mark just for him to get that df2 for
nobee coming in again two rounds
straight round three i mean just like
that it was a convincing two round
straight too i feel like dan has finally
kind of sealed off uh nobody's offense
here i mean what's he gonna do and i'm
glad if nobody could prove me wrong but
right now he's in a bad position but
they're a clutch whip punish
let's see what he does he gets the wall
now having the likelihood that's huge
whoa bro
bro the pickups
[Laughter]
emphatic fashion nobody's still in this
but yep
next round let's see if he can still
sustain this momentum
oh
he wasn't expecting
wasn't expecting it to hit his counter
hit but still it got some decent damage
out of it
look at the likely den is looking to run
away with this here but again nobody
can't count him out he was able to make
a huge comeback in that last round
oh never mind never mind again
well that last round right the previous
the second to the last round we saw like
some glimpses of hope for nobi but
i don't know i think it's the violet
systems like this is really um this is
the stage where uh again really kicks it
up a notch and usually when the round
starts or like it's faint it's it's
nobody that gets the first few rounds
but on that last one uh again was really
making a statement there he was he's he
was saying like yo i i i i adjusted
accordingly i'm able to snipe you out my
df2s i'm able to interrupt you you have
been blocking my slides he put it all
together there and now very earned is
his spot in the grand finals and again
uh yeah going to the grand finals and
now we see that nobody will be facing
double in the losers finals
and that one should be a doozy because
right now we've seen